it's not okay
a little bit of evidence respectfully i
have not said it
i have not said it is okay ma'am your
question is i want to be clear
i can't believe you would ask me a
question indicating
that it's all right just to doctor a
little bit of evidence
conservative outrage at the media's
coverage of the capital riots has
continued
to boil over making matters worse the
new york times has quietly retracted its
story
about the death of capitol police
officer brian siknik
on january 8. the times wrote that
sicknick died from brain injuries that
he quote
sustained after trump loyalists who
overtook the complex struck him in the
head with a
firing extinguisher but now medical
experts are saying that's not true
and the paper is backpedaling admitting
that it's possible
he was never even hit at all joining me
now is
molly hemingway federalist senior editor
and a fox news contributor
molly is that retraction enough i mean
this
story went on for weeks it was used as
evidence
in the impeachment trial what do you say
about this
well this death of this officer brian
sicknick is so sad and i feel horror
counts
on the record said that he was a loving
and lovely man
and his death became something of a
political football because the new york
times
falsely reported the circumstances of
his death it's very important to get the
facts right they allowed
anonymous sources who they previously
claimed were law enforcement officials
but now seem to be saying we're not law
enforcement officials
to talk about the circumstances of his
death in a false manner and they did
it for political purposes our media
unfortunately are so corrupt that
they're willing to put forth a false
story a knowingly false story
um in some cases and use it for
political gain
for weeks or even months or even years
at a time and then they think they can
quietly backtrack when the reality is
too difficult for them to ignore
they did retract this but they did it
quietly they didn't admit they were
retracting it but the
the update shows that they were
completely wrong in what they reported
and it really caused a lot of harm to
the to the national debate that we were
having
at a very important time this is just
one example of
how false the narrative has been about
the situation that's going on in this
country
in the in a general sense but also in
this very specific sense about what we
were dealing with
at the capitol on january 6th yeah i
mean it's perplexing to me why there
wasn't a full investigation
prior to the impeachment i mean there's
a lot of questions still out there
um no one knows who placed the pipe
bombs um
you know why hasn't the journalists the
media really followed up
on on these questions
well even if you take the issue of how
policing was done on that day
right someone who covered the the rally
and then
later was near the capitol the thing
that struck me so much was the complete
lack of policing it was
very different from the rallies and
marches that i've covered in the last
few decades in washington dc it was
noticeable to me
we still haven't gotten any answers
really about why that was
we know a little bit we know that the
mayor of d.c muriel bowser didn't seem
to want
the necessary policing of course capitol
police report
to the house and the senate which means
there are some pretty tough questions
for nancy pelosi and mitch mcconnell who
were then at the time in charge
uh to answer about why they didn't
prepare for this right one of the things
about the impeachment is that they were
claiming that this was something that
was
that everyone would have known that this
type of thing would have happened well
if that's true
why didn't they have proper policing
even without knowing that unrest would
occur you would normally have for that
size of a crowd
a far higher police presence and yet
people aren't interested in discovering
that they're so interested in just
pushing a political point and not
actually informing people there is so
much we need to know
and unfortunately i don't think that we
have a good approach to finding out more
about
you know who was involved and how
policing decisions were handled and
and who's really responsible right and
that might be very well why you know as
soon as the question of witnesses came
up
um in the impeachment trial they quickly
wrapped up the tent and said okay
everybody let's go home
um do you think that that they were
afraid of getting those kind of
questions because no one understands why
nancy hasn't been asked about that
well just in general we have so much
that we need to
learn about this and you've heard some
people on the left say that there needs
to be some type of
you know commission to investigate
what's going on in order for that
commission to have
any credibility it needs to stop making
this all be about
you know this this town washington dc's
hatred for one man
and really be about finding the truth
and answers and even more than that i
think we need to
be thinking about uh you know what what
led to all sorts of unrest in this
country you know whether that's
you know whether we need to know more
about what happened with the summer of
rage and the attendant riots this
this summer that besieged so many cities
throughout the country
or frustrations with how our 2020
election was handled
and whether we can sustain that type of
election in the years to come
but unfortunately our media are not
interested in looking into
any of this they're they want to say
that there are you know that people who
believe differently than they do
uh don't have valid reasons for
believing that and it causes a lot of
problems and breakdown in
in in american society yeah well i was
just going to ask you if you think this
is going to get worse with the media i
mean we already had so many concerns
coming into this administration um that
you know he just
that joe biden and his administration
just weren't going to be asked
um the questions and be challenged and
and have their narratives challenged and
um i think you've answered the question
for us molly
so all right thank you so much for
joining us today
coming up